was there movie time in jail or not yeah
they do and the people look forward to
it yeah bro what are some of the bangers
that they were playing do people ever
like reschedule the riots because it's
movie night
oh my God we're about to kill that no no
they're gonna play
they played Air Bud do you guys remember
yo they played an airplane he's like get
out of here we don't want you anymore
that scene bro
try to make it like soften us up and
then and then there was a yard where
they had dog training so you're allowed
to have dogs come in a pet dance there's
like a non-profit I forgot the name of
it they help like the inmates dogs for
dogs
[Laughter]
that they would play I like Air Bud and
then the fact that they had dogs right
after that
you're petting the dog as you watch it a
lot that makes sense that they would try
to show movies that would be like gentle
rather than like Prison Break blood and
blood out Shawshank Redemption over and
over don't get any ideas